Michel Marie va être avec nous dans un
instant on va revenir sur quatre
affaires qui ont marqué les Français
parce que ça rebondit partout le petit
Émile qui a disparu depuis 8 juillet
dernier et alors que l'enquête semblait
avoir ralenti une nouvelle perquisition
a eu lieu Lina cette adolescente de 15
ans qui a disparu il y a un mois et n'a
toujours pas été retrouvé malgré de
nombreuses pistes et témoignages il y a
de plus en plus de pistes sur Lina et il
y a l'affaire jubilar aussi qui va être
clôturé après 3 ans d'enquête malgré de
nouveaux détails troublants et enfin on
va revenir sur la macabre découverte du
corps de la petite Lana dans une cave de
Sedan après sa desparition mardi soir
petit récap et Michel Marie sera avec
nous juste
après Poret disparu depuis le 8 juillet
dernier l'enquête autour du jeune Émile
continue et hier une perquisition a été
menée par les gendarmes de Marseille une
disparition inquiétante qui faitcho à
d'autres celle de Delphine jubilard et
de Lina qui connaissent de nouveaux
rebondissements de véhicules citadins de
couleurs clair et sombre ont retenu
l'attention des enquêteurs qui cherchent
le moindre indice et aujourd'hui c'est
un éè fait Diver qui vient bouleverser
les Français avec la décou couverte du
corps sans vie d'une jeune fille de 10
ans dans une cave cette gamine là elle
était plein de vie elle demandait rien à
personne perquisition pour retrouver
Émile témoignage troublant sur Lina
nouveauté dans l'affaire jubilare et
fillette de 10 ans morte dans une cave
Michel Marie fait le point sur les
affaires ce soir dans
TPMP alors merci Michel Marie d'être
avec nous alors on va revenir sur déjà
l'affaire jubilard on va rappeler
l'histoire c'est bien sûr Cédric
jubilard avec
le dans la nuit du 15 au 16 décembre
delphine jubilard a disparu du domicile
conjugal qui était situé à Cagnac les
mines c'est son mari Cédric qui donne
l'alerte il est 4h30 du matin les
gendarmes vont arriver rapidement sur
place ils font ils vont faire des
investigations longues minutieuses des
recherches qui
n'aboutiront jusqu'à aujourd'hui en tout
cas qui n'aboutiront
pas Cédric jubilard apparaît assez
rapidement comme le suspect numéro numé
1 l'unique suspect même l'unique suspect
et le suspect numéro 1 parce que il a
son Fran parler parce qu'il y a quand
même des éléments qui les accumuler les
uns aux autres finissent par devenir
quand même un petit peu gênant
euh il y a une histoire de lunettes
cassées on retrouve une paire de
lunettes cassées euh c'est les lunettes
de Delphine or
euh en général quand on casse ses
lunettes enfin en tout cas dans l'esprit
des des magistrats et des gendarmes
c'est dans ce cadrelà une suite à une
bagarre il y a des témoins qui ont
entendu vers 11h du soir des des cris de
de femmes qui provenaient a priori de la
maison du couple jubilard il y a
également le fait que la voiture était
la voiture de Delphine était toujours
garée d'une certaine façon or ce jour-là
elle était garé d'une autre façon c'est
le capot vers l'avant là c'était le
capot on on va revenir sur l'affaire
parce que elle date hein euh ils ont
clôturé l'enquête alors qu'on ne sait
toujours pas ce qui qui s'est passé euh
et on na toujours pas retrouvé le corps
de Delphine alors on n'a pas retrouvé le
corps de Delphine effectivement les
magistrats instructeurs ont décidé de
clôturer l'enquête c'estàd de de de
faire ce qu'on appelle l'article 175 qui
est la la clôture de
l'instruction ils ont quelques jours
pour que les avocats leur fassent part
de quelques demandes de de
contre-expertise par exemple et ensuite
ça ils vont faire ce qu'on appelle une
ordonnance de mise en accusation et ils
vont renvoyer Cédric jubilard devant la
Cour d'Assise voilà alors quelles sont
les dernières infos les dernières infos
elles elles émanent du des avocats de de
la de la famille de de Delphine euh au
tout début lorsqu'il appelle les
gendarmes à 4h30 du matin euh quand les
gendarmes se présentent à son domicile
il est en pyjama et les gendarmes un peu
plus tard quand ils vont réaliser que
l'affaire est quand même d'une d'une
extrême gravité ils vont saisir ce
pyjama donc on sait que c'est le pyjama
qui qui portait le la nuit de la
disparition et à partir de là ils vont
l'envoyer au laboratoire et là on sait
maintenant qu'il y avait des traces de
salives au niveau du dos au milieu du
dos plutôt en haut sur le pyjama et pour
les enquêteurs c'est la preuve qu'il il
aurait pris sa sa femme comme ça par les
par le en face à face par la taille il
l'aurait soulevé elle aurait eu donc la
tête qui basculait sur le dos de l'autre
côté et la bouche sur le sur le ama ça
c'est la théorie deaccusation il lui
clame toujours son innocence hein lui
clame toujours son innocence alors euh
donc sur cette affaire donc c'est la
nouvelle information qui est importante
qui est importante sur ça ça ça rebondit
on a aussi des nouvelles de l'affaire du
petit Émile le petit Émile he ce garçon
de de de 3 ans c'est ça 2 ans et demi 2
ans et demi exactement qui a disparu il
y a combien de temps maintenant il a
disparu il y a 3 mois début début
juillet ex plus une nouvelle de minute à
l'autre incroyable toujours pas retrouvé
le 8 juillet ouais 8 juillet et il y a
une nouvelle perquisition qui a eu lieu
pour le petit Émile pourquoi et o alors
la perquisition a eu lieu au hameau de
rousimat c'est un petit hameau qui est à
3 km du haut vernis c'est dans la maison
qui appartient à une famille de riches
agriculteurs apiculteurs également et on
est toujours sur le même suspect que les
genses avaient dans le collimateur au
tout début c'est toujours le même celui
avec la voiture celui avec voiture qui
roulait très vite avec son tracteur sauf
que là ils ont fait deux perquisitions
une perquisition dans la maison et ils
ont refait une perquisition sur le
terrain parce que ils ne connaissaient
pas les coutumes les GES connaissaient
pas les coutumes agricoles en fait les
les ces gens avaient retourné la terre
mettre du pour mettre du fumier pour
faire pousser des des patates c'est ce
qu'on m'a expliqué j'ai appelé le Le
Vern cet après-midi et donc il les
gendarmes voient de la terre retourner
donc il pensent que peut-être quelqu
quelque chose à à rechercher à cet
endroit-là donc ils ont fait venir du
matériel pour creuser et ils n'ont rien
trouvé en fait il il intéresse beaucoup
les les enquêteurs parce qu'il conduit
de manière brutale son engin agricole
donc ça relance la testse d'un éventuel
pas que mais ça relance la test d'un
accident qui aurait pu être maquillé
ensuite ouais mais c'est toujours le
même c'est toujours le même personnage
il le fait avec sa moto avec son quad il
sa figure et cetera mais c'est lui qui
était dans le collimateur dès le départ
absolument et cette famille a des TER
qui vont jusqu'au auut vernis donc il
connaît très bien la région et d'autre
part le cousin de ce jeune homme ce
jeune agriculteur est l'un des témoins
qui a vu Émile donc ils se disent vous
savez il y a deux témoins qui ont vu
Émile le J la il très critiqué dans le
village ce jeune homme très critiqué il
est pas intégré du tout tout bah il est
pas aimé parce qu'il conduit mal
brutalement la famille n'est pas aimée
voilà donc soit c'est un règlement de
compte c'estàd qu'on a dénoncé des gens
parce qu'ils sont pas aimés soit
réellement autour de cette famille parce
que ça fait deux fois que les enquêteurs
il reviennent soit il se passent quelque
chose autour de cette famille ils sont
pas aimés pour d'autres raisons aussi
parce que la maman de de ce jeune
adolescent euh est sur la liste
d'opposition à la mairie donc il y a des
rivalités de dans ces petits villages au
niveau de de la mairie et puis c'est
également des gens qui sont jalousés
parce que c'est des gros travailleurs
ils ont une affaire qui tourne bien ils
ont un commerce de viande de charcuterie
et cetera et ils ont un gros chiffre
d'affair d'accord donc ils ont un beau
commerce euh on va revenir sur l'affaire
Lina Lina cette j'père que vous avez
tous suivi on va rappeler l'histoire
Lina qui a disparu comme ça elle aussi
et on va rappeler l'affaire parce qu'il
y a du nouveau Lina c'est le 23
septembre elle quitte son domicile à
saintblaise la roche pour se rendre à la
gare pour prendre le train en direction
de Strasbourg pour rejoindre Tao son
petit copain elle se perd en route en
tout cas elle disparaît en route et
depuis on est on est sans nouvell d'elle
des des des investigations ont été
menées là depuis depuis le mois de
septembre et là encore ça n'a
malheureusement pas donné grand-chose
alors euh un crime commis 9 jours avant
la disparition de Lina inquiète les
enquêteurs pouvez nous expliquer cette
affaire parce que c'est ça qui ça
rebondit là c dernier alors Lina
disparaît enfin en tout cas son
téléphone portable se coupe à 11h22 or
il se trouve qu'à 7etteh précise à 11h22
c'était les obsèques d'un homme qui a
été assassiné 9 jours plus tôt à moins
de 50 km de là dans un petit on retrouve
son corpsyable au château du Haut conix
coenixburg conixburg et cet homme est un
prof de ma inconnu des services de
police un ancien sacristtin qui est veuf
qui a refait sa vie qui est un grand
sportif qui fait du vélo qui fait de la
natation et cetera il se balade il fait
de la randonnée en permanence et des PR
l'ont retrouvé donc le jeudi 14
septembre criblé de balle sur un petit
sentier près du château de du haut de
coning merci alors la mère de Taou a reu
des propos étranges au sujet d'une
blessure aux jambes et qu'elle se
trouver dans une maison ou une usine
abandonnée on en sait plus est-ce qu'on
en sait plus ou pas cette histoire ou al
c'est quoi elle la mère de Tao est venue
à à rejoint son fils quand elle a appris
que que Lina avait disparu et elle est
en connexion avec des voyants c'est la
mère de Tao est en connexion avec des
voyants petit ami de Lina la petite ami
de l non c'est petit am petit am de l la
mère du petit ami de Lina ouou ou et
donc cette femme don je connais pas le
le nom cette femme est en en relation
avec des avec des voyants et a priori il
y aura un voyant qui lui aurait dit que
Lina était blessée aux jambes qu'elle se
trouvait dans une maison où ou peut-être
dans une usine désaffectée à une
vingtaine de dans un dans un rayon de 20
km ce qui explique d'ailleurs
probablement que Tao soit allé
ensuite rechercher Lina en montant sur
le toit de l'usine désaffectée c'est
l'endroit où il a perdu son téléphone
portable qu'a donné l'inspection du
téléphone que Tao a perdu on pas retour
encore parce qu'ils l'ont retrouvé quand
ah ils l'ont retrouvé j'ai plus la date
mais oui ça un téléphone vous me le
donnez je le fais en 2 minutes he et
alors euh ça peut comme il y a du
WhatsApp c'est ça prend peut-être plus
pr non mais j'en sais rien moi c'est pas
de ma faute s'ils ont pas encore rendu
les résultat à mon avis il les ont non
je crois pas ils sont pas les résultats
non je crois pas ah ouais donc ça fait
une semaine qu'ils ontet trouvé le
téléphone moi j'ai un mec qui qui qui
qui a perdu son téléphone j'ai j'ai un
petit doute les gars c'est le premier
truc que je fais je regarder son
téléphone direct je dit bon ben c'est
bon les gars ou bien c'est pas lui non
mais souvent ça peut aussi partir dans
des labos privés qui sont pas forcément
à la disposition de de l'autorité
judiciaire en tout cas et puis il y a
ils ont énormément de boulot chercher ce
qui a été
effacé sûr bien sû éé effacé mais bon
déjà on peut regarder ce qu' ils ont dû
regarder ce qu'il y avait déjà Michel ah
bah oui non mais je vous dis pas qu'ils
ont pas regardé je vous dis qu'ils ont
pas rendu en tout cas les résultats ok
donc ta n'a pas de téléphone pour
l'instant ta il a un autre téléphone
mais c'est pas c'est pas un autre
téléphone